aber die bundespolitik berichten und
unsere aufgabe ist es pressekonferenzen
zu veranstalten unserer mitgliedschaft
damit sich unsere mitgliedschaft
umfassend informieren kann das nur als
kurze vorbemerkung und jetzt vor köcher
haben sie das wort bitte schön das sind
ja schon sehr viele wahlanalysen gestern
abend erfolgt ich denke dass man das
ergebnis auch noch mal vor dem
hintergrund der gesamten
legislaturperiode sich anschauen muss
weil die gekennzeichnet war von einer
enormen volatilität insbesondere bei der
unterstützung für die cdu/csu
und auch bei den grünen denn wenn man
sich über die legislaturperiode hinweg
einmal einfach mal anschaut wie die
cdu/csu sich entwickelt hat dann hat man
2018 schon mal einen abrutsche man hat
dann 2009 10 in der ersten jahreshälfte
eine begrenzte erholung dann wieder
einen abrutscher mann hatte sah dann die
rücktrittsankündigung von frau
kramp-karrenbauer
dann kam anfang zwei
krone und da schoss die unterstützung
für die unionsparteien innerhalb von
vier wochen hoch von unter 20 unter 30
prozent auf annähernd 40 prozent
und das gibt dann lange zeit stabil bis
zum beginn dieses jahres als auch
innerhalb von vier wochen die
unterstützung plötzlich wieder steil
durch sagt und ich glaube diese
volatilität muss man sehen
und bei den grünen war wirklich
interessant dass sie in mehreren phasen
unterstützung aus ausbauten 2017 erstmal
weil die leute das gefühl hatten das ist
eine zwangsehe diese große koalition und
die grünen hatten
regierungswillen bekundet und waren
ausgebremst worden
namens sie schon mal zu in der
unterstützung dann
kamen auch diese diese freiheit ist
future demonstrationen das klimathema
wurde immer bedeutsamer auch für die
bevölkerung insgesamt und das war die
zweite phase des aufstiegs und dann kam
in diesem jahr noch mal so ein richtiger
hype zwischen januar und april dieses
jahres und
einen rückgang der sicher auf die grünen
dann selber überrascht hat in den
monaten danach
das hatte zum einen damit zu tun dass
eine partei
die vorher fast lag wie ein brett
nämlich die spd die sie hat fast über
die gesamte legislaturperiode eine sehr
geringe schwankungsbreite gehabt und
dann plötzlich man kann sagen im
entscheidenden moment von anfang august
an stieg die unterstützung für die spd
steil an und das hat natürlich auch sich
auf die grünen ausgewirkt neben dem
thema das sicher auch schon in den in
der heutigen pressekonferenz behandelt
worden ist auch gestern behandelt worden
ist dass man einige fehler
gemacht hatte aber auch wir haben in
umfragen gesehen das interessanterweise
der anteil der bevölkerung der
nachteile von den grünen erwartet
bemerkenswert hoch war also wir fragen
immer so vor einer wahl von welcher
partei erwarten sie nachteile von
welcher vorteile wenn sie ganz
entscheidend an der regierung mitwirken
kann und da waren die grünen
bemerkenswert hoch von daher hatte man
da dann auch viele die dann doch noch
abgesprungen sind
und was natürlich sich in den letzten
wochen aus wirkte das verstärkt über
rot-rot-grün spekuliert wurde und das
ist die koalition von der eine mit mit
am meisten von der bevölkerung erwartet
wurde dass sie deutschland schaden
könnte und das hat auch die werte für
die grünen mit
beeinträchtigt
das problem ist natürlich wenn man jetzt
die ausgangslage sieht dass weder
jamaika noch eine ampelkoalition
die
bevölkerung von vornherein mit großem
vertrauen erfüllt also knapp zwei
drittel sind überzeugt dass eine solche
koalition eher probleme hätte effizient
zusammenzuarbeiten dass die
meinungsverschiedenheiten nicht zu groß
sind die
bürger trauern ein bisschen den zweier
koalitionen nach weil sie zunächst
einmal überzeugt sind dass da die
spannungen am geringsten sind und machen
da interessanterweise auch überhaupt
keinen unterschied jetzt bei den dreier
konstellationen zwischen der ampel und
jamaika und ich denke das wird jetzt
sowohl für die fdp wird nie für die
grünen ist das eine sehr schwierige
situation weil wenn man in die partei
sympathien ihrer anhängerschaften
hineinschaut welche partei ist für sie
die 2 10 pa tische und welche
konstellationen werden befürwortet in
den anhänger kreisen von fdp und von
den grünen dann sieht man natürlich dass
viele anhänger der grünen eine koalition
favorisieren ich hier mit der spd und
umgekehrt sie mehrheit die große
mehrheit der anhänger der fdp eine
koalition mit der cdu/csu also von daher
kann man jetzt gespannt sein wie sich
das entwickelt ein thema das man sich
unbedingt anschauen sollte im nachgang
zu dieser wahl ist das thema briefwahl
da war diese wahl ja wirklich einmalig
ein steiler anstieg des anteils der
briefwähler und
ich denke das wird man jetzt in den
nächsten
wochen und monaten sich auch noch sehr
genau anschauen was das mit einer wahl
macht wenn der wahl zeitraum so
gestreckt wird wie das diesmal der fall
war und von daher die wähler natürlich
in einem ganz unterschiedlichen
bezugsrahmen abstimmen und das zweite
ist natürlich auch die frage unsere
vorstellung von einer individuell freien
und geheimen wahl wie weit lässt sich
das durchhalten wenn zuhause abgestimmt
wird oder irgendwo im privaten raum
abgestimmt wird
die
ich denke dass man wirklich über das
thema briefwahl diskutieren muss wie das
mit diesen vorstellungen wirklich
kompatibel ist
die der wahlkampf das noch abschließend
wurde von den wählern als deutlich
interessanter als frühere wahlkämpfe
empfunden
gleichzeitig waren sie ziemlich
missmutig und der anteil der sagte
keiner der kandidaten liegt mir und
die themen es findet keine richtige
kontroverse über wichtige themen statt
der anteil war sehr hoch wir hatten noch
lange zeit einen hohen anteil an
unentschieden aber gleichzeitig wurde
diese wahl als besonders spannend
empfunden und die
frage ist natürlich
wie sich jetzt die nächsten wochen
entwickeln die spannung bleibt ja jetzt
erst mal ist es völlig offen wer diese
republik regieren wird außer dass
relativ klar ist dass wahrscheinlich fdp
und grüne in der regierung sein werden
zu personen sag ich jetzt erstmal nichts
weil dazu soviel veröffentlicht worden
ist im detail am wahlabend aber auch in
den wochen zuvor
dass da eigentlich wenig überraschend
dass neues zu sagen ist herzlichen dank
frau köcher dann herr jung bitte ja
meine sehr geehrten damen kann
ich bin jetzt seit 30 jahren in dieser
funktion und habe öfters diese
pressekonferenzen unmittelbar nach der
bundestagswahl erlebt und ich will
zunächst mal die gelegenheit nutzen
darauf hinzuweisen dass wir anders als
bei vielen anderen bundestagswahlen wohl
jetzt nicht unter irgendwelchen
schlagzeilen leiten müssen die da so
getitelt sind das versuchen versagen der
demoskopen das sind artikel die in
vielen redaktionen schon vorher
geschrieben worden sind und von daher
möchte ich einfach mal darauf hinweisen
ohne dass man jetzt auf einzelne punkte
und detail eingehen dass zumindestens
entgegen der vielen unkenrufe die auch
vorher veröffentlicht worden sind das
meinungsbild dass wir auf der
bundestagswahl ebene in den letzten
wochen monaten in den verschiedenen
umfrageinstituten gezeigt haben
offensichtlich ganz sinnvoll den
entscheidungs und willensbildungsprozess
bei dieser bundestagswahl abgebildet hat
und will gerade diese gelegenheit auch
noch mal dafür nutzen jetzt nicht zu
sagen ja wir haben vernünftige prognosen
gemacht sondern ganz im gegenteil das
gleiche sagen was wir bei anderen
scheinbar falschen prognosen in den
vergangenen jahren den letzten
bundestagswahlen oder bei anderen wahlen
immer wieder vorgehalten bekommen haben
wir können als seriöser meinungsforscher
mit dem was wir an umfragen erheben denn
das methodisch sauber machen damit keine
prognosen liefern sondern wir können
wenn wir das saubermachen die politische
lage zum zeitpunkt der durchführung der
umfragen wieder geben und das ist schon
eine ordentliche leistung und damit
können wir diese prozesse abbilden und
deshalb sind differenzen bildung
zwischen den letzten veröffentlichten
umfrageergebnissen und dem wahlergebnis
was anschließend rauskommt vom ansatz
her schon eine falsche entscheidung
dieses zwischen diesen zeiträumen auf
den letzten vier oder fünf tagen sind
die menschen noch nicht genötigt worden
ihre entscheidung zu treffen wir messen
die wahl
absicht einige tage davor und dann haben
wir bei den wählern zumindestens
entscheidungen die sie treffen können
und da haben wir inzwischen halt wenn
man das mal auch über die jahrzehnte
sieht ganz entscheidende strukturelle
unterschiede zu früheren zeiten als
viele wählerinnen und wähler deutlich
stärker an ihre parteien den ideologisch
auch nahestanden gebunden war und dann
ist es natürlich kein hexenwerk dass es
dann weniger veränderungen einstellen
weil die menschen
unabhängig von der aktuellen tages
performance dann dabei bleiben
jetzt haben wir bei dieser
bundestagswahl relativ wenig veränderung
in der letzten zeit in den letzten tagen
erlebt wissen ja zwar wichtige punkte im
hinblick auf die mehrheitsfähigkeit aber
wir haben keine großen massiven
taktischen wahl veränderungen erlebt und
oh wunder dann sind natürlich die
stimmungsbilder die man vier fünf tage
vor der wahl erlebt dem wahlergebnis
ähnlicher wenn wir eine wahl die 2017
gehabt haben wo wir zum beispiel einen
großen swing zwischen der fdp und der
cdu noch auf den letzten metern erlebt
haben dann können die meinungs- befunde
der meinungsforschungsinstitute einige
tage davor das wahlergebnis nicht
treffen weil es wäre sehr unseriös
irgendwie eine glaskugel zu bemühen das
wollte ich aber nur als vor rede da
lassen damit war auch mal eine situation
wo man keine schelte kriegt man den
gleichen punkt machen kann wie den den
wir sonst benutzten um entsprechende
umfrageergebnisse
zu verteidigen
aus meiner sicht ist in der tat schon
viel gesagt worden ich will mich erst
mal auf einen punkt kaprizieren weil der
sowohl auswahl soziologischer sicht als
auch
in hinblick auf das tat solche
stattgefundene ergebnis von großer
bedeutung ist und das ist das
wahlergebnis der union
wir haben in der vergangenheit eine sehr
starke strukturelle unterstützung für
die union erlebt die sozusagen etwas mit
der primär sozialisation der wählerinnen
und wähler zusammen hängt die wir
natürlich dann im westen deutlich in
deutlich stärkerem maße vorfinden als im
osten und haben normalerweise zum
beispiel bei den älteren wählerinnen und
wähler einen ganz klaren bonus für die
cdu/csu umgekehrt bei den grünen bei den
jungen und wir haben jetzt gesehen dass
eben halt gerade sozusagen in dem kreis
derjenigen ich würde es nicht als
stammwähler und nun bezeichnen aber
diejenigen die der union am nächsten
stehen olaf scholz und die spd
knapp vor der cdu csu gelegen ist und es
hat natürlich schon ausgesprochen
dramatische ergebnisse auf die
strukturelle unterstützung der union und
im prinzip können sie zwei parallelen
dazu bilden wir können einmal eine
parallele zur bundestagswahl 1998 sehen
wo auch da die älteren wählerinnen und
wähler
der cdu csu und die rote karte gezeigt
haben und dort damals die massiven
einbrüche gewesen sind und auch hier bei
dieser bundestagswahl ist es der union
nicht gelungen ihre strukturelle
überlegenheit insbesondere bei den
großen anteil der älteren wähler zum
tragen zu bringen das hat natürlich was
damit zu tun dass die union
vordergründig einen kandidaten
präsentiert hat der einfach keine
ausreichende unterstützung in der gesamt
bilder schafft gefunden hat aber noch
nicht mal eine halbwegs über durch
richtig überdurchschnittliche
unterstützung in der
potenziellen wählerschaft von ihr und
insbesondere damit sehr stark abgefallen
ist und wir haben ja auch daten
präsentiert das eben ein ganz großer
teil sowohl in der gesamtheit der
wählerschaft als auch bei den cdu csu
anhänger schafften eigentlich mit einem
anderen kandidaten der vor auch zur
debatte stand ein deutlich besseres
ergebnis erzielt hätte es sind extrem
viele fehler gerade auch im wahlkampf
der cdu csu gemacht worden wovon
natürlich immer über das lachen bei den
flug bildern berichtet worden ist aber
das ist glaube ich nicht der
entscheidende punkt sondern der
entscheidende strukturelle fehler der
bei der union zu beobachten ist ist eine
entwicklung die letztlich die ganze
legislaturperiode
vorgeherrscht hat man hat nämlich nach
der letzten bundestagswahlen und den
landtagswahlen ergebnissen nieder
eingetreten sind letztlich
eigentlich der kanzlerin die schuld
allein im rückgang des wahlergebnisses
auf das wahlergebnis
2017 zugewiesen und sie mehr oder minder
aus der position des parteivorsitzenden
gedrängt in der illusionären hoffnung
dass man durch eine profilierte
konservative ausrichtung der union
bessere ergebnisse erzielen kann als es
in der vergangenheit unter merkel der
fall gewesen ist und diese illusion die
durch keine befunde in der repräsentativ
befragten bevölkerung und auch ein
potenziell anhängerschaft der union
unterstützt werden kann die aber der
mentalität der altersmäßig völlig
überalterten mitglieder
sprich die aus früheren politischen
sozialisation stammen hat man eine
partei vorsitzende verschlissen man hat
corona bedingt viel zu spät einen
parteivorsitzenden neuen gewählt einen
kanzlerkandidaten viel zu spät etabliert
der neue vorsitzende hat sich nicht
primär darum gekümmert wie kann ich
wählerschaften binden sondern hat sich
der innerparteilichen meinungsbildung
und sinnfindung
gewidmet und letztlich damit ist er zu
spät an der urne erschienen und dann
wurde neben im performance fehler noch
stärker angelastet aber letztlich hat er
es versäumt den ausreichenden linke
ebenfalls früh genug zudem von aus ihrer
strategisch eigentlich zu
präsentierenden
link zu einer erfolgreichen
bundesregierung und einer erfolgreichen
kanzlerin hinzukriegen und ist dann in
eine situation geraten wo ausgerechnet
der kanzlerkandidat der spd in der
anmutung und der ganzen art und weise
der präsentation und der themen am
ehesten den eindruck erweckt hat dass er
in der kontinuität der kanzlerin die ja
bis zum schluss sehr hohe sympathiewerte
genossen hat steht und damit auch einen
teil nicht alleine aber auch ein teil
durch eine sehr traditionelle nicht
linke positionierung der spd in
wählerschichten eingedrungen ist die
eigentlich in den letzten jahren
legislaturperioden merkel durch ihren
modernisierungskurs unter anderem auch
der spd abgenommen hatte das vielleicht
einfach zu diesem schwerpunkt mal
kommentiert einige thesen dazu
formulieren herzlichen dank dann herr
siege bitte ja ein herzliches willkommen
auch von mir ich habe kein eingangs
statement vorbereitet weil wir nur die
vielen ard-landesrundfunkanstalten
quasi rund um die uhr berichten seit
tagen und wochen und ich freue mich auch
über das eingangs statement von herrn
jung der ja noch einmal festgestellt hat
dass man nie formal erhebung mit
prognosen verwechseln sollte das ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt und deshalb ist
dieses mal vielleicht keinen demoskopen
bashing aber das ist eigentlich völlig
irrelevant weil im prinzip vorwahl
erhebungen die prognosen sind wenn man
prognosen macht sowie das für ard und
zdf die macht wurde gestern abend auch
live gesendet dann haben die anderen
anspruch und dann hat man auch gesehen
dass dort die abweichung relativ gering
sind ich möchte eigentlich keine großen
neuen erzählungen hier einbringen
sondern 23 punkte aufgreifen die schon
genannt wurden ein kleiner schlenker
vorweg vielleicht aus meiner eigenen
beobachtungen herr jung hat er gesagt er
mache das schon seit 30 jahren ich bin
seit 30 jahren politikwissenschaftlern
habe wahlen und wahlkämpfe in vielen
ländern miterlebt und es fiel mir doch
im vorfeld dieser wahl auf mit welcher
mit welchen engen blickwinkel auch in
der berichterstattung
hierzulande eine kritik laut war die bei
einer vergleichenden einordnung der wahl
und deutschland bei dieser
bundestagswahl völlig anders ausgefallen
wäre
und ich fange damit an dass gestern die
wahlbeteiligung gestiegen ist also wir
hatten 2017 einen erheblichen anstieg
der wahlbeteiligung
durch eine asymmetrische mobilisierung
vor allem bei der afd und wir haben
gestern noch mal eine leicht gestiegene
wahlbeteiligung erlebt und
offensichtlich war es dann doch so dass
viele wählerinnen und wähler vielleicht
angesichts des offenen rennen um platz
eins aber vielleicht doch nicht ganz so
wenig überzeugt waren dass die angebote
an inhalten und personen so schlecht
sind es ist häufig in der wahlforschung
schwierig wenn man aktuelle
zufriedenheitswerte dann vergleicht mit
werten von vor 20 oder 40 jahren als wir
im prinzip noch einem zweieinhalb
parteiensystem waren aber im endeffekt
war es so dass mehr menschen ihre von
ihrem stimmrecht gebrauch gemacht haben
dass in dieser situation
auch deutlich zu vernehmen beim
wahlkampf dass wir portiert
unterschiedliche
positionierungen der parteien des
mittleren spektrums hatten bei wichtigen
kernfragen des landes wie wirtschaft und
sozialpolitik die umwelt und klimaschutz
und natürlich soziale sicherungen das
kann sowohl in den formal erhebung als
auch in den nachwahl erhebung gestern
sehr gut zum ausdruck
und mit dieser gestiegenen
wahlbeteiligung sind dann doch einige
befunde noch zu ergänzen von dem was
schon gesagt wurde
der blick ist heute ein bisschen
verstellt durch die zugewinne der spd
die weitere rückläufige anteil der
klassischen volkspartei in an
wahlstimmen hat doch diese war sozusagen
keinen bruch erlitten das ist ja eine
lange historische trendlinie lange
historische trendlinien sind gibt es
dann immer meine gegenbewegung aber der
blick auf das wahlergebnis gestern zeigt
dass eben spd cdu/csu mittlerweile
weniger als 50 prozent der wählerstimmen
auf sich vereinen das lag gestern wie
schon gesagt wurde vor allem an den
verlusten der union die über vier
millionen wählerinnen und wähler im
vergleich zum wahlergebnis
2017 verloren hat die wie jung gesagt
hat für langjährige beobachter von
wahlkämpfen doch vielleicht nicht
überraschende und trotzdem erstaunliche
strategische fehler im wahlkampf gemacht
hat sie waren deshalb nicht wirklich
überraschen weil die nachfolgefrage von
angela merkel nicht
vernünftig geklärt werden konnte und
wenn man sich dann zwei dinge an schaut
nämlich die kompetenzwerte der union
über sämtliche politikfelder eine
illusion eines kompetenzprofils und
natürlich vor allem in dem bereich
wo es darum geht wirtschaftliche
kompetenz kompetenz zuschreibung von
wählerinnen und wähler von denen spreche
ich nicht die objektiven der
wissenschaft oder von politik
feldforschung das war eine massive
erosion des kompetenz feldes und es war
ein kandidat ein kanzlerkandidat er zu
keinem zeitpunkt die mehrheit der
deutschen wahlberechtigten von seiner
tauglichkeit für das kanzleramt
überzeugen konnte es wurde vorher schon
kurz erwähnt allein das
lächeln in der hochwasserkatastrophe
kann aus einer wahl soziologischen
sichtweise jetzt auch nicht als zu sagen
die einzige negative als erklärungs
variable herausgegriffen das hat
bestimmt die images natürlich verstärkt
das ist unstrittig aber zu keiner zeit
war armin laschet letztendlich in der
mehrheit der bevölkerung an
kanzlerkandidat dem dieses am zugetraut
wird das kam unmittelbar vor der wahl
und auch am wahlsonntag noch mal in den
nachwahlbefragung deutlich zum ausdruck
dagegen konnte der
spitzenkandidat der sozialdemokratie
stärker überzeugen in einer dreier
konstellation ist es wenig
wahrscheinlich mit annähernd ähnlich
starken parteien dass einer von teilen
dann irgendwie zwei drittel der
wählerinnen und wähler von sich
überzeugt das heißt das sind die
relative knappheit verhältnisse
natürlich auch in einer fragmentierten
landschaft anders ausgedrückt hätten wir
in den tagen vor der wahl noch einmal
laschet versus scholz zum beispiel als
möglicher kanzler gegenüber gestellt
hätten wir krasse unterschiede gesehen
die auch weit in das bürgerliche lager
hinein reichen bis in die fdp
wählerschaft die natürlich inhaltlich
bei vielen fragen häufig näher der
anhängerschaft der union ist aber weil
der frage welchen kannst du sie
präferieren wurde eben stärker zur olaf
scholz nein der unterschied zu
1998 ist nach 16 jahren unions regierung
20 21 dass die rote karte nicht am ende
einer sehr sehr langen kanzlerschaft dem
einen kanzler damals helmut kohl gezeigt
wurde sondern die rote karte quasi im
vorfeld einer kampagne und einer
strategie der union und einem
spitzenkandidaten in einem ausmaß wie
wir das uns wahrscheinlich anfang des
jahres nicht hätten vorstellen können
diana